let me ask you about yourself your own
self who mentioned richard rangham
think about mortality do you think about
your own mortality
are you afraid
of death
yeah interesting i'm not afraid of death
um i agree with with richard wrangham i
i i'm not eager to leave the party i
don't want to leave the party soon
i enjoy life
in all of its interesting complexities i
enjoy
my scientific work i enjoy my
relationships with other people i enjoy
exploring the universe so i'm not eager
to to leave but i'm not afraid of it and
i think
um part of that is that
um i was married for a while and um my
wife died
uh prematurely uh of cancer and so i
spent basically eight months with her
watching her diet she after she was
diagnosed and there's some weird it's a
horrible time for me and for her
obviously but there's some way in which
it kind of um
made it more familiar so that it's
became a lot less frightening
you know um
but um
how did that experience change you
just as a scientist as a thinker about
humanity
as a as a human yourself well i guess so
you're saying you felt
like you felt a little bit more ready
for this whole
end of the party well or yeah it's yeah
we tend to be
afraid of things that we're not familiar
with you know and so if you're familiar
with it
um
at least in my case that that caused a
lessening of um fear on that dimension
but
i don't know i it also kind of you know
there are these existential
thoughts that it brought about like how
ephemeral
life is and um and i remember this
richard dawkins quote he said something
like um
we are all going to die
and we're the lucky ones
you know
uh yeah that we got
we even got a chance yeah or even uh you
mentioned russian writers one of my
favorite writers is uh nabakov vladimir
nabakov i don't know if you've read
him but he he said once that
life is
a [ __ ] of light between two eternities
of darkness
and you're saying that's not terrifying
to you
well i i'd prefer i'm happy with the
prior the first eternity of darkness i
prefer the second um not to occur but um
but it's going to occur i mean it's um
we know that uh
um elon musk aside i i i'm
skeptical that we'll be
colonizing other planets in any
substantive way
and so our our star our sun will will
burn out
and so it might it's going to take a few
billion years or so but
um it will eventually the earth will
become a cold lump of um
dirt
floating around in the universe with no
life on it so it's not just
your light the light of your
consciousness
it's the light of
our human civilization that will
eventually go out yes everything
at least here
i do believe that there is life and
intelligent life in other
parts of the uh universe on other
planets
i sometimes wonder
if
the second eternal darkness
is the thing that makes the light
possible so in in the other places out
there
um i wonder how successfully can you
truly be without the deadline and of
death both at the human scale
and at the civilizational scale
i feel like we in order in order to
create anything beautiful we have to
live at the on the edge of destruction
that seems to be
um you know some people would say that's
just the feature of our past
that our future can be otherwise but
you know like you i'm uh somebody that
looks at the data
and currently the data says otherwise
but uh
of course we're constantly changing the
data because we're there's change
so we'll see what we see i wonder what
the future uh future holds for us
speaking of which as a
you know as somebody who
wrote the textbook on
evolutionary psychology
what do you think is the meaning of the
whole thing
what's the meaning of life
um you're very good at describing how
the human mind is the way it is
but why is it here at all
what's the purpose well i can give you
my answer to that but i would actually
love to hear your answer because i know
you've asked this question of dozens and
dozens of people on your podcast and
what what are what are your thoughts on
that well first of all my mind changes
on that at all a lot and i think the
process of answering the question is the
fun thing
not the actual final answer i think the
question itself is the most fun thing
but for me usually
is
two things
one is
love
and we can talk a long time what i mean
by that is not just romantic love
and two is to create and hopefully to
create beauty
so
and again i can talk forever what that
means for me personally
creating beauty means
engineering
and creating experiences like connection
with others
on the love side
it's just
the actual feeling the experience
of deep
appreciation of um
everything around you like the sensory
experiences of everything around you
just feeling it every single moment
saying
i'm damn glad to be alive
that light with the darkness on your
side just being appreciative like being
in the in the experience of
of truly
present and experiencing it
because um
because it's not going to be there for
long the whole thing ends and that that
to me is love and
the the reason romantic love is so
important is um
is that other people are just awesome
they're uh they're
fascinating black boxes that can
generate awesomeness
so can like other animals and objects
for me but uh humans in particular for
some reason are just generators of
awesomeness yes they surprise us
yeah
yeah and therefore a good uh target of
love
well so that's a much more uh eloquent
answer than um than i could give but
i'll just say a thought or two on that
and
i mean one of the things
that
you know what is the meaning of of life
i mean in some sense
um
if you're thinking about some eternal
purpose
meaning like if we
look five billion years hence you know
will any of this mean anything i think
the answer to that is probably no okay
but
and this is i think where my answer
would concur with yours is that i think
we have a rich
evolved psychology that contains
many complex
adaptations
and at any one moment in time
most are quiescent most are not
activated
uh but
for me part of the meaning of life is
experiencing
the activation of a lot of these
complicated evol psychological
mechanisms and they include
romantic love they include friendship
they include
being part of a group or coalition
because i think we're an intensely
coalitional species so there's something
about being a group
member so like just even i don't know if
you're in in sports if your your team
wins you feel that somehow that's your
part of that
um
and but this goes for both the positive
and the and the uh darker sides of
things so
so for example
warfare
um you see these
men who have been through a war together
and who where their lives have depended
on each other and they're like
best friends for for life and have a
bond that is
stronger than most people form with a
friend ever in their life because
they've been through the these life or
death
experiences and so
you know i i wouldn't want to um
you know
doesn't cause me to want to charge off
and be
in war but
uh but there are some
types of adaptations even like warfare
adaptations where in principle
i would like to experience them i would
like to experience and and never will
but uh you know what is it like to be
in a
coalition where you are in combat with
another coalition and not not in modern
warfare because it's it's you know
horrible but where your life is in
danger where your life
you
depend for your life on other people and
they're depending for their life on you
and there's this kind of coalitional
solidarity that is
um is unique
now um
another thing that of course i'll never
be able to experience is is murder
because i'm never going to murder
anybody okay but
he's young but studying homicidal
ideation really gave me a it wasn't it
was an eye opener it was as interesting
as
studying sexual fantasies because
the if you ask what triggers homicidal
thoughts ideation most people have had
them uh and uh and i because i asked
this question have you ever thought
about killing someone
and and i get that 91 percent of men say
yes about 84 of women say no
and even when i talk to people they say
uh one-on-one they'll say oh no i've
never thought of telling someone what
kind of person you think i am and then
10 minutes later i say actually there
was this one time when i got this guy
humiliated me in public and i
you know and and so but i think um
thoughts about
killing um homicide ideation and they're
very predictable from an evolutionary
perspective if you look like we
mentioned mate poachers earlier and
uh infidelity and there are other things
but
things like that being humiliated in in
public status loss you know do trigger
homicidal thoughts
so so uh anyway i don't go off too much
on that but i guess what i'm saying is
answer to your question is
is
experiencing the rich array of
complex psychology that we have within
us
most of which
remains unactivated and some of which
will never be experienced um
like you know there's some people who
never never experienced love for example
because
of you know cultural restrictions or or
whatever and so
uh to me that that's part of the meaning
of life so that's that's so beautifully
put to saying that they're kind of
dormant inactivated aspects of
the uh
so the psychological mechanism so we
have the capacity to experience a bunch
of stuff it's almost like in video games
you can unlock levels and so on
and so this is basically
there's all of these things that are
dormant in our mind that we have the
capacity to experience
and part of the meaning is to try to
experience
um as many of them
or
as many new ones novel for the
particular society or maybe the entirety
of human civilization who knows
psychedelic drugs
like you said violence
uh experiences that might have to do
with brain computer interfaces the
interaction with all of those are
experiences and so the question is what
is the ceiling what are like
how uh
infinite or nearly infinite is the
capacity of the human mind to experience
all those things and we'll get to uh
we'll get to discover those things so um
i'm glad you never got a chance and
never will get a chance to murder but i
just want to put on record that uh
um
you know that's definitely something on
my bucket list why do you think i dress
like this
anyway um
there is something appealing like one of
my favorite movies is leon the
professional oh i love that movie
what is that why is that so exciting
listen maybe it's the ocd thing
like killing other bad guys
no women no children women no children
uh also loving that with uh uh
natalie portman incredible actress uh
also the complex whatever that is the
fatherly or romantic whatever that is
like lolita type of thing i don't know
what i i've never like
read a phd thesis on that interpretation
of that movie but
that's a fascinating one violence and
violence and love and sex that's what
makes uh life worth living that's what
makes it fun david you're an incredible
person an incredible scientist it's a
huge honor to share a city with you or
i'm i'm the visitor you own this place
you run this place oh i don't i we vote
we both live here now yeah and uh
it's been great talking to you it's a
great honor for me um i mentioned i've
followed your podcast for a long long
time now and
tremendously enjoy your your interviews
and
uh you have a very um
inquisitive
inviting style that brings out things in
your guests which i think is fantastic
activates all those dormant
psychological mechanisms that's what
that that's a life that's what
conversation is all about thank you for
talking today thank you